Goldman Sachs no longer expects the FED
to hike rates in March cities stress on
banking system this is a CNBC story that
just came out uh a a
this comes out after regulations
analysis measures to prevent the spread
of contagion following the collapse of
Silicon Valley Bank and enclosure of
Signature Bank citing system systemic
risk in the light in light of distress
in a banking system we no longer expect
the fomc to deliver a rate hike as its
next meeting on March 22nd said Goldman
Economist uh John hatsu's on a Sunday
Noel Goldman has previously anticipated
a 25 basis point hike last month the
rate Federal Reserve opened
Federal Open Market Committee increased
the federal funds rate by a quarter of a
percentage point to a target range of
4.5 to 4.75 its highest since 2007 the
bank still expects to see 25 basis point
hike in May June and July with a
terminal rate expected to be at 5.25255
what do you think Tom is he going to
increase it or is going to stay flat and
not do anything for a minute first of
all I gotta remember who's talking here
Goldman Sachs is talking and hasn't had
the best of quarters has been laying off
people and there's even been uh you know
some very carefully written articles
talking about David Solomon but Goldman
said this on Sunday Goldman is lobbying
to go back lower because it helps the
banking industry it helps them get
cheaper money
um that's what they're begging for and
by the way Goldman is the same guys that
worked with Silicon Valley Bank you know
from uh two weeks ago and couldn't get
the deals done and couldn't get all that
put together so this is Goldman I think
just just kind of out there you know you
know curfing for moisture just trying to
you know grab a little bit and and and
Lobby the other banks that are out there
saying hey given a little uncertainty we
think 50 basis points off the table
probably just be 25. I think that's
we're going to see but this was Goldman
on Sunday lobbying and hoping in my
opinion and and they're in a weak
position they haven't had a good couple
quarters as you've seen I guess my
question is you know you got Goldman
saying some things you got Barclays
saying some things you got the bond King
Jeffrey gun like saying some things
everyone's going to give their opinion
on this
is Jerome Powell going to be swayed by
anybody
Jerome Pyle is on a mission right now to
bring down inflation he's fighting that
with the interest rates obviously
unemployment's also a factor uh
Jerome Powell he's been battle tested
he's been through multiple
administrations at this point
um
is he going to continue the course with
these rate increases is he going to
stand Pat as as the bond King Jeffrey
gundlach kind of pointed out
um that that remains to be seen like is
a bank failure or multiple bank failures
like this enough to
um
diverge his his expedition of of
increasing rates he's done a pretty good
job of saying sort of uh agnostic to
what the presidents have to say and what
banks have to say you saw that his uh
interaction with what was that Senator
Kennedy Kennedy uh the other day in
Louisiana yeah Louisiana winning he gave
him a little breakdown right there of
all the interest rate situations I'm not
picking on you I just want an answer
I'm cotton picking answer so listen but
gonna like the bond kick said the
following is to save the central bank's
credibility they will probably raise
rates 25 basis points I would think uh
uh that the uh I would think uh that
that would be the last increase he galag
does not think that the Federal Reserve
is going to slow down because of this
there's there's a lot of different uh
perspectives here there's Goldman saying
one thing there's gun like saying one
thing there's Bloomberg saying one thing
Bloomberg says Federal Jerome Powell uh
plans to raise interest rates at a
faster uh Pace to curb inflation has
been disrupted by the collapse of
Silicon Valley banking signature which
has cost Financial instability meaning
they're saying that he may not now is
this a indirect way of Bloomberg and
Goldman trying to talk to Powell to get
him to say don't do it by putting fear
in there who knows yesterday Megan Kelly
hosted a debate I don't know if you
was on there with David sacks
everywhere right it was a very very good
debate and Vivek didn't back down about
his argument and they actually went at
it it was a very good position both of
them presented a very good argument
Vivek said you went out there and you
put so much fear that they finally said
fine here's what we're going to be doing
we're going to do a backstop and bail
out the customers and he's saying that
is still the wrong move and David is
saying you're being irresponsible to
think what you're thinking I'm thinking
about more the people and then Vivek
said these are people that you know they
have they're not the small time business
owners they're the bigger ones it's not
just a small and middle income guys that
are being hit the point is we don't
really know what Powell's going to be
doing I I don't know if Powell's the
type of guy that is super predictable
where he's going to I think he is a
sensible guy that he can be convinced
but he also has a backbone meaning which
is exactly place to be I put him a high
score for being able to reason in this
specific context
I see him hearing out from everybody
that calls him and saying hey
they probably have a list you know they
probably have a list of banks that are
next can you pull up the the list of
banks that are next uh uh you just put
like the next Silicon Valley Banks who's
on the list of the next Silicon Valley
Bank whatever if you search it it'll
come up they have a list of banks that
they're looking at and they know where
they're at because they have many of
these guys have to report their names
and the more these lists become public
lists
okay meaning if there's new names that
pop up think about what you're thinking
if you have your money in that bank
you do not want to be on any list right
now by any credible Source at first you
understand what I'm saying so so isn't
the list to be on no so imagine the call
being made to Jerome to say hey uh
Jerome here's what you need to know
if you increase the rates you will
officially be the First Federal Reserve
chair
to have seven bags go under do you want
that part of your legacy
let me say this one more time Jerome
Powell if you raise rates quickly like
you've been doing there's another seven
banks that are like Silicon Valley Bank
that are going to get hit and they're in
the top 38 and they're 100 billion Outer
Banks do you want that part of your
legacy and Jerome has to really think
about that
he really has to think about this
especially when you look at FDIC and
FDIC he's got how much money 125 billion
can you look at how much FDIC has right
now
if you go look at how much FDIC is right
now I saw a number the other day 35
billion as of yesterday or something
like that how much does what what did
they have okay this as of 2022 but do
they have the number as of 2023 okay so
they have 128 billion
uh uh give or take to cover one point
1.26 of a total 9.9 trillion so that's
not billion trillion right so I do think
Jerome has to think about his next move
and how quickly increases rates I do
think he has to think about that because
he will could potentially the fear that
the opposing side could put on him as
you will be known as the the chair where
the most banks went under under your
leadership I don't know if he wants that
and I don't even know if that even does
anything to his decision making process
well we talked about yesterday we had a
guest on yesterday who talked about that
he thought with the new uh depositor
protective in place that protects
against the bank run because everybody
can calm down there and say you don't
have to run the bank if something ever
happened to your bank you know there's
going to be a backstop from the federal
government and this 25 billion dollar
fund that's been set up and I said I
thought there was a 25 chance of of it
happening and specifically I meant you
know first Republic because there are
and I characterize them yesterday as I
do now as they're kind of hopping on one
leg
um and and that's where it's that's
where it's going to go so
I and I I'm not changed from yesterday
even though I read a ton of stuff early
this morning pbd
if there's ongoing Jitters which really
seem to be calming pretty quick in
banking I think he backs off the 50
because he doesn't want to Jitter the
system but he's going to keep going
after inflation and I don't think it has
to do it's really interesting the
central bank's credibility what do you
mean credibility this is not a thing
where you say I did what I said I was
going to do no things happen the economy
moves around we just saw over the
weekend a lot of things happen sometimes
pretty damn quick and so I think he
looks at it and says is everything
calmed down enough are we going to Spook
the system no okay well then I'm
continuing with 0.25 because we got to
continue this March against inflation
and I think he's got a backbone I
thought he looked pretty impressive we
were making fun of Kennedy and I'm sorry
that anybody was offended by me using
that voice but I thought Jerome Powell
handled himself pretty well and pretty
stable I think so at that hearing oh
yeah by the way I just Paul Rob just did
a quick poll 97 of the audience was
offended by the way you yeah
condescending approach towards the
candidate you know oh good afternoon let
me buy everybody a nice red flesh let me
let me read a super chat here by Paul
which which is kind of interesting so
shout out to Paul uh uh Powell will
continue to raise rates stress testing
the vulnerable ones then bail them out I
mean backstops Shore up the bank making
them even more powerful As Americans get
crushed and lose okay powerful or
powerful well there's a play on words
yeah I like that powerful but you know
you seem powerful by the way there's a
part of what he's saying that he's got a
very good point because think about it
this way
if if you know the establishment and if
you know if these guys truly want to
eliminate smaller Banks and to make this
thing even more nationalized this is
where I do it it's centralized banking
if if that is truly the agenda hey
Jerome Powell if you really want to do
that don't raise it by quarter don't do
half go three quarters of a basis point
if this guy goes half of 100 if he goes
half or higher then there's a community
of people that will say I think they
kind of do want to get rid of the
smaller Banks and bring them together I
don't know Paul if I'm there where you
are right now but if it does happen
uh there's an argument for that for sure
because it is strengthening the top four
or five banks that uh they would sit
there and say big thank you I'm sure if
uh Powell raised the rates anything half
or higher he may get a nice bottle of uh
wine and some nice cigars from the top
five banks in America saying hey right
you're amazing so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]